welcome back to las vegas now let's head
to nevada coin mart where you can sell
your jewelry and your coins
safely
hi welcome to nevada koi mart come in
let me show you around
shoes shirt face mask required as soon
as you walk in
we have the mask for you and the hand
sanitizer
we're always looking out for you we have
the security checkpoint
he's going to ask you say hi how can you
help you and you're going to say what
you'd like to do
let me continue the tour over here
i am the main sponsor for the injured
police officers fund that's the ipof
the most wonderful organization for all
the police in
all of the whole entire state of nevada
the only thing that i
buy sell and trade coins paper currency
bullion any type of products like this
here we have the spot price
of gold silver platinum and palladium
that on display for you
here's all the coins and currency that
we do sell
buy sell and trade let me tell you the
other thing that i got for you
i got booth nine what's booth nine
that's where we take care of larger
items you know why because i buy
silver plate i buy sterling silver
flatware
we do larger items here back here this
is part of my
six privacy windows everything is done
with
social distancing for you no one is
going to be near you
and we're here to do business let me
tell you the other fun thing i got for
you
this is the most beautiful store so when
you come in
we're going to look at what you have
we're going to evaluate it
we're going to make sure that we give
you the very best price my name is neil
sac murray my name is on the building
let me tell you this when you want to
sell you want to go to the number one
guy in las vegas
gold silver costume jewelry coins paper
currency bullion
silver and turquoise jewelry did i tell
you that
i love costume jewelry i want to sort
your jewelry box for free
i want to buy your entire coin
collection all you need to do
is get up get out of bed get to the
corner of jones and flamingo
this is my only location so all you need
to do is get here because i'm going to
be waiting for you
to have cash in hand if you want to get
paid
and you want to get paid the most value
for what you have there's only one place
to go in las vegas
one neil sac mary nevada coinmark on the
corner of jones and flamingo
gold silver costume jewelry coins paper
currency
i want to buy what you have i want to
buy and look at
all your costume jewelry your estate
jewelry
your vintage jewelry maybe you have
something that's been passed down
maybe you don't know the value i offer
free verbal appraisals
all you need to do is come down and see
me i'm waiting for you
right now thank you for that tour neal
give them a call at 702-998-f-o-u-r
thousand or visit neilbuys.com we'll be
right back here in las vegas now